it's going to take some people coming
back home
to the community it's going to take
people
who have achieved educationally maybe
professionally who make a conscious
decision to say you know what
the hood needs me
my neighborhood needs me
there are some young boys that need
positive mentors
[Music]
what's up everybody i'm still here can
you believe it i am still here on this
rooftop that's right my name is pastor
corey brooks and i'm living in this tent
for 100 days from november 20 to
february 28th bring awareness to the
violence in chicago but not just bring
awareness to the violence in chicago but
raise money to build a community center
on this block that's called oh block old
because it's named after a young man
named od perry who was shot and killed
the gangs picked up his name the letter
o in his name and started calling it oh
block we decided we're gonna keep the o
for opportunity block we're about making
opportunities and today i'm like really
excited to have with us a young man who
is now part of our staff but it's his
story that i want you to hear about and
and his commitment to what he's doing
now uh today i have with me brian
alexander brian how you doing i'm good
good i'm good thank you for having me so
brian let's jump right in because we
don't have a lot of time um
how did you get here i mean
how did you get here tonight yeah so so
pastor brooks has actually been my
pastor since i was about 12 or so years
old when we were still when new
beginnings was actually still inside of
a uh
a school auditorium we were sharing
space in there in doolittle down on 35th
street uh so i spent some of my very
very formative years uh here growing up
in the church uh growing up in this
community as well as we transitioned to
our new site uh here on king drive i and
i so i took some time and went away to
school
uh and spent some time at howard
university in washington dc uh where i
had a chance to study political science
and then go on to
to go to law school and kind of spend a
lot of time really in that race uh
chasing the things that people chase in
those sorts of circles uh and and
honestly long story short once once
covey hit and had a chance to really
kind of sit down and evaluate my life
you know and being in dc you really
think that that machine needs you to run
uh and everyone thinks so so much of
themselves but i really began to realize
that
that
my heart was really very much empty
because i wasn't able to give back uh in
the way that i really want to i saw in
the media how chicago was really being
portrayed uh people were drawn to me
because i was from chicago but not
necessarily because of me but because of
the things that they saw and they
associated
with chicago the things that the media
had associated
with chicago and it was just really
really important to me to not waste
another day uh of my life and of my
of my gifts that that i have uh as well
so i after cover was over i came back in
market to start to volunteer here i
really felt like there was no better
place for me to be uh and to have
immediate impact uh rather than here at
project food and i
the rest is pretty much
history you know what i want to say
something because here's a success story
here's a young man who's been with us
since he was 12. how old are you now 35
so he's 35 now so here's a young man
who's been with us for a long time
and
you grew up in the hood
not only did you grow up in the hood but
you
went to school
educated yourself got a law degree
and
you worked in dc
but realized it wasn't fulfilling
and
being involved in government isn't
always the most fulfilling thing
yeah and you decided to come back and
work in the hood
why is why work
why come back and work in the hood why
is that so important yeah because
exposure is really everything man i
if we're not for the individuals who are
in my life that that were in the church
and just hanging up hanging around i
they really enabled me to really see
that there was more out there for myself
and more more in
in me as well i and i really do believe
that you can't be what you can't see so
it's important for for me to yeah to
come back and really like just be the
best version of myself that i could
possibly be because i know there are so
many young people who are watching uh so
many folks so many ways in which that we
get to
to interact and affect and positively
affect the lives of those who are in
this community uh as well and honestly
just to come back and just love on my
community right to be an example of
someone coming back to where they're
from and not leaving where they're from
and investing and then sticking with it
in order to see it become what you know
that it can be and be
and really help to deliver a life and a
community that that these residents
really do truly deserve
you know what and that's what it's going
to take
it's going to take some people coming
back home
to the community
it's going to take people
who have achieved educationally maybe
professionally who make a conscious
decision to say you know what
the hood needs me
my neighborhood needs me there are some
young boys that need positive mentors
and so we want to encourage all of you
who are educated and professional
man please come back home help us in
this endeavor to transform a
neighborhood because that's what it's
really all about brian thank you for
being part of project hood and helping
to run our organization thank you for
being back and thank you for being a
positive example thank you so much for
having me i appreciate it thank you all
for joining rooftop revelations and
until tomorrow
peace
you